bonjour aujourd'hui 20 novembre nouvelle
édition de votre journal de fin de
semaine voici les principaux titres à la
campagne des régionales suspendu mais le
scrutin aura bien lieu les 6 et 13
décembre difficile de savoir quels
incidents seront les attentats sur les
résultats invitée aujourd'hui pour en
parler et pour parler aussi de ses
propositions thierry mono tête de liste
yvelines pour lutte ouvrière comme
chaque vendredi retour sur les
principaux sujets que nous avons traité
cette semaine 1 mais essentielle de la
semaine consacrée principalement aux
attentats de paris et puis notre
séquence regard de jeunes sur l'actu
sera elle aussi dédiée aux événements
toujours une séquence réalisée au
collège les saules à guyancourt l'état
d'urgence prolongé donc hier par la
quasi totalité des députés trois mois
supplémentaires durant lesquelles des
mesures spéciales pourront être prises
pour assurer la sécurité du pays le
préfet des yvelines a ainsi convié les
maires pour leur préciser les
dispositions prises c'était à versailles
vous envoyer les images écouter à
présent serge morvan le préfet
l'objectif des services de l'état est
évidemment mon objectif premier c'est
d'assurer la sécurité des yvelinois et
de s'assurer qu'effectivement il là ils
pourront continuer à vivre normalement
avec quelques évidemment difficultés
d'organisation de certaines
manifestations qu'il faut parfois
interdits parfois sécurisé ça n'est pas
en accapare car nous avons un dispositif
général et particulier que nous avons
explicité expliqué au maire nous avons
également tout un dispositif de
perquisitions administratives qui sont
menées depuis dimanche
nous en avons effectué 22 dans le
département et il y en a d'autres qui
sont prévues pour les les journées à
venir mais
et question d'organiser y compris
d'ailleurs un moment je vous parle
quelques-unes sont en train d'être
organisées nous avons également les
assignations à résidence d'assignation à
résidence qui sont décidées par le
ministre il y en a eu six l'un des
yvelines au moment où je vous parle qui
ont été notifiés à ceux qui doivent être
assigné à résidence
nous avons également tout ce qui est
sécurisation des centres commerciaux
voilà pour ces dispositions prises
pendant l état d'urgence dans le
département mais aussi dans l'ensemble
du territoire français la prière du
vendredi pour les musulmans avait une
teneur particulière aujourd'hui une
semaine déjà après les attentats de
paris différents textes condamnant le
terrorisme ont ainsi été élus dans
plusieurs mosquées en france à la
demande du conseil français du culte
musulman une volonté de réaffirmer leur
rejet de toute forme de violence avait
l'isolation
les horreurs et amertume
que nous avons suivi les événements et
les attentats ayant ravagé la france
vendredi 12h 30 jours des plus
importantes prière de la semaine dans le
calendrier musulman différents textes
condamnant le terrorisme ont été lus à
l'initiative du conseil français du
culte musulman
le prêche à la mosquée de montigny le
bretonneux a été consacrée au respect de
la vie le problématique c'est que un
certain nombre d'individus qui se
réclament de l'islam et qu'ils disent
ils on fait telle tel acteur pour la
criminelle
donc on est obligé en fait de répondre à
ces personnes l'islam est tout à fait
étrange de ses actes et c'est même le
contraire que l'islam prêché l'amour
condamne fermement ces types d'actes
barbares et impitoyable tout simplement
parce que l'islam c'est préserver la vie
une façon pour les musulmans de
réaffirmer leur rejet catégorique de
toute forme de violence ou de terrorisme
négation même des valeurs de paix et de
fraternité que porte l'islam quasiment
d'angeac préférant faire vivre
normalement pas vraiment là ils ont
occupé par mot de fraternité
l'ouverture des changes de millercoors
pour l'humanité l'association des
musulmans de montigny le bretonneux qui
hors caméra nous a exprimé ses sincères
condoléances et son soutien aux familles
des victimes
je reçois pour cette édition du vendredi
thierry gonot bonjour je vous êtes
candidat aux élections régionales en île
de france 7 de liste yvelines avant de
parler de votre campagne votre réaction
malgré tout aux événements et notamment
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence la
quasi unanimité de l'assemblée à six
voix près et qui a voté pour
est ce que c'est une bonne chose bien la
pomme déjà jeu
tiens à dire que évidemment les 130
victimes 129 et les 350 blessés
évidemment tout toute notre attention va
à eux et à leurs familles
ça c'est une première chose je crois la
plus importante
ensuite la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence
nous on est contre parce que s'il s'agit
de faire taire toute toute critique
vis-à-vis de la politique que mène le
gouvernement ou que mène le patronat et
qu'on puisse pas sont posées et dire ce
que l'on pense de ça
lutte ouvrière dénonce l'unité nationale
aujourd'hui oui aujourd'hui oui parce
que l'unité il peut pas y avoir pour
nous d'unité nationale pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord en politique intérieure
on estime que la politique qui est menée
au profit des grands actionnaires et que
les toutes les doigts qui protégeait un
peu les travailleurs sont attaqués le
code du travail
l'elfe là on facilite les licenciements
et voilà la salsa c'est aujourd'hui ce
cadre là on one un cadre ils
l'arrêtaient du pays et en extérieur
nous avons dénoncé à l'époque la guerre
au mali la guerre en irak et en syrie
donc aujourd'hui pour quelle raison on
serait d'accord avec ça donc l'unité
nationale derrière cette politique là
non nous voilà aujourd'hui avec ces
événements la campagne a été suspendu
par de nombreuses formations politiques
que ce soit les socialistes que ce soit
les républicains aussi est ce que c'est
le cas pour nous non absolument pas on
pense que justement les gens qui ont
perpétré ces attentats sont des gens que
je qualifierais d'extrême droite et qui
interdit chez eux quand ils sont au
pouvoir comme la en ce moment un fracas
celle ci l'a en syrie et en irak
ils interdisent les libertés à tout le
monde et les femmes ont elles n'ont plus
aucun droit
et bien qu'ils veulent non refuse qu'ils
interdisent la liberté ici donc on
continue à dire ce qu'on a à dire est ce
qu'il fallait reporter le scrutin du 6
et du xiii où je ne crois pas le
contexte n'est pas forcément une
influence une incidence cette proximité
immédiate avec ces événements et cette
situation aujourd'hui sur le résultat
des élections
écoutez ça peut avoir une incidence
c'est sûr
voilà le scrutin c'est comme tout le
tout le reste on peut pas arrêter de
vivre parce que parce que des gens nous
l'interdisent
on va parler de votre candidature
puisque la campagne le scrutin en tout
cas lui est maintenu même si certaines
formations mettent la campagne entre
parenthèses parlons de votre candidature
vous êtes employé dans le domaine de
l'industrie automobile dans le
département à l'usiné renault de flins
depuis quand vous êtes engagé à lutte
ouvrière et puis et puis pourquoi je
suis engagé à lutte ouvrière depuis une
trentaine d'années parce que bon ben je
suis né dans un milieu ouvrier
traditionnelle et que voilà on a
toujours été confrontée aux difficultés
aux difficultés de trouver d'abord aux
difficultés financières pierrot
difficulté trouver du travail
et puis voilà ça continue donc
l'engagement il a été assez
naturellement l'automobile qui est un
secteur important dans le département
des yvelines c'est aussi un des secteurs
qui est le plus touché par la crise
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu'on
fait peu de choses finalement pour les
travailleurs du secteur automobile j'ai
travaillé un renouveau à écouter
aujourd'hui ce que je dénonce et que du
travail en à l usine de flins il ya 1750
intérimaire voilà ce qu'il n'y a pas
assez d embauche en contrat à durée
indéterminée donc voilà c'est une
politique de l'emploi qui vise à au
moins 10 ans qui vise à payer le moins
possible les gens sauf qu'on expliquera
aussi tient peut-être pas de contrats
qui sont pérennisés c'est parce que
c'est très fluctuant les commandes non
ça fait des années
ça fait au moins dix ans que l'auto
d'intérimaires et autour d'un millier
c'est une volonté politique de la
direction de ne pas embaucher
concernant les licenciements vous
réclamer des mesures pour les interdire
oui parce que l'interdiction des
licenciements on dira certains diront
oui mais c'est pas réaliste
écoutez
il ya une autre mesure qu'on préconise
c'est l'ouverture des livres de compte
la fin du secret bancaire et commercial
bien là on verrait que où va l'argent et
que les entreprises elles n'ont elles ne
sont quasiment jamais obligée de
licencier que c'est pour faire encore
plus de profits souvent pour conforter
des actionnaires c'est souvent des
licenciements boursiers comme on
l'appelle est donc oui on est pour la
levée du secret bancaire et commercial
et l'interdiction des licenciements mais
là dans le cadre des régionales
aujourd'hui quel pouvoir à la région sur
sur ces domaines là sur l'interdiction
des 10 danses des licenciements parle
notamment d'écouter le pouvoir de la
région évidemment c'est au niveau de
l'ensemble de l'état mais le pouvoir de
la région là dessus il est quand même la
région n'est pas isolé et donc ce que
subissent aujourd'hui les travailleurs
il ya 5 millions cinq cent mille
chômeurs et on continue à en continu
comm sa
voilà mais nous on pense que non et donc
on pense que c'est un des problèmes
principaux qui se posent aujourd'hui à
la société à l'ensemble de la population
française
l'une des compétences du de la région
c'est le transport notamment et vous
réclamer la gratuité pour les
travailleurs dont les transports oui
nous réclamons la gratuité
parce que tout simplement il faut savoir
que deux environ 200 milliards par an
sont données aux entreprises aux banques
sous forme de dégrèvement de toutes
sortes on a vu le cio récemment le cic
etc
et c'est cet argent qui est de l'argent
public qui est le contribuable alors le
contribuable
c'est les impôts directs sur le revenu
mais c'est aussi toutes les tailles
toutes les tv 1 c'est à dire qu' il n'y
a pas de les travailleurs payent tous
l'impôt d'accord donc et bien cet argent
public il est dilapidé en dons qui ne
servent à rien au rang des entreprises
qui continuent leur politique de
licenciements oui on pense que pour avec
cet argent là on pourrait entre autres
rendre gratuits les transports en commun
par exemple un exemple au simple
quelqu'un qui veut chercher du travail
qui habite mantes-la-jolie quelqu'un qui
va à paris chercher du travail
l'aller-retour ses 17 trous et pour pour
des tas de familles c'est insupportable
bon donc oui c'est une mesure avec qui
meurent qui me paraît nécessaire
on avait quelques-uns des points de
votre programme un plus globalement
aujourd'hui
lutte ouvrière n'est pas la première
voix à gauche comment vous pouvez leur
devenir soit simplement quelles sont vos
ambitions dans le domaine bien écouter
pour déjà il faut faire entendre ce
qu'on a à dire ce que c'est le plus
compliqué on n'est pas souvent invités
donc on ne fait pas la une des journaux
donc oui on pense que dire aux
travailleurs aux gens aux retraités
qu'il ya une autre politique que celle
qui consiste à soutenir les entreprises
à financer les entreprises à arroser des
entreprises il ya une politique qui est
possible en faveur des travailleurs pour
ça il faut une volonté il faut un
certain nombre de mesure qu'on avance
comme l'interdiction des licenciements
l'ouverture des livres de comptes des
entreprises
voilà mes
pour l'impôt pour l'instant nous nous
voulons défendre ce programme
et dire que tous ceux qui vont aller
voter
il ya d'autres possibilités que de voter
pour la gauche ou pour la droite qui
mènent la même politique c'est voter
démocrate vous républicain banon il ya
on peut voter 8 ouvrière et ce sera un
vote d'opposition à la politique et
d'opposition du côté de la classe
ouvrière du côté du front national
résister on a vu aussi beaucoup
d'électeurs de gauche historiquement qui
votait pour la gauche se tourner vers le
front national
on leur dit quoi à ses électeurs bien
qu'ils se trompent qu'il regarde un
petit peu ce que dit le front national
las pour les salades les salariés d'air
france par exemple qui a dit le front
national marion maréchal-le pen a parlé
du lynchage des calmes florian philippot
lui a parlé d'homme qu'il était content
qu'on ait arrêté à l'aube
c'est un travailleur comme comme mais en
nous on ne pense pas ça on pense que la
violence là dedans c'était celle des
3000 licenciements
la chemise des cadres une heure après il
y en avait une
mais quand c'est sur la chemise c'est la
scène de violence et la gêne ans qui
savent qui a été à l'encontre d'une
personne plus que l'image de la chemise
mais en tous les cas nous on est du côté
des travailleurs et qui se défendent
y compris chez air france et ça c'est
clair et le front national n'était pas
du tout le front national
le père banque est hors jeu maintenant
et lui il était pour la retraite à 70
ans faudrait un peu développé ce que
veut le front national et on verrait
qu'il n'est pas du côté des travailleurs
et je dis à tous les travailleurs qui
votent front national qu'ils ont tort et
qui regarde bien
une dernière question ces élections
régionales ont forcément un enjeu sont
forcément un enjeu important pour le
national est ce que ces résultats vous
allez les regarder à la loupe justement
pour l'avenir de votre formation
politique est ce qu'ils sont
particulièrement importants pour
l'avenir de notre formation politique
non pas spécialement
nous allons
défendre on est une fois de résultats
voilà quel que soit le résultat on sera
l'allemande main et on sera dans les
entreprises on sera dans les quartiers
auprès des travailleurs des gens de la
population pour mener les combats à
mener
voilà donc pour nous mais bien sûr les
élections toujours une incidence les
résultats des élections ont toujours une
incidence ni même si elle n'est pas
direct pour notre organisation
merci thierry benoit est revenu sur ce
plateau vous êtes candidat tête de liste
des yvelines pour la liste lutte
ouvrière donc sur la région ile de
france merci à vous je rappelle que
treize listes sont engagés sur notre
région dans cette campagne l'actualité
est à suivre sur notre antenne dans le
journal quotidien vous le savez et puis
dans le 7-8 politique aussi le mardi et
dès 18h30 et les prochains invités
d'ailleurs de la semaine prochaine david
douillet pour les républicains et
vallerand de saint-just pour le front
national on passe au résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
comme chaque vendredi retour sur
l'actualité de la semaine écoulée une
actualité largement dominé par les
attentats parisien
samedi soir vingt-quatre heures après
les attaques paris pleure ses morts ici
dans la rue du restaurant le petit
cambodge ce sont des scènes d'horreur
que les riverains découvrent avec
consternation
l émotion aujourd'hui lundi toujours
aussi forte et la communion de la nation
lors de la minute de silence il était
midi lorsque la france s'est figé en
mémoire des victimes comme ici à magny
les hameaux en salle du conseil
municipal à l'hôtel de ville moment de
recueillement en hommage aux 129
victimes et 350 blessés
un premier temps où toulon s'est allongé
par terre ou pris un premier tireur qui
est arrivé qu'il a globalement a balayé
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient au couteau dont
c'était les fans un petit peu
particulière parce que forcément on a
des centaines de la faim fait des
fichiers de pour certains être présent
ce soir c'est revivre un drame question
personnellement vécu
alphonse marché devant le restaurant au
moment de la fusillade
un moment donné et j'entends malgré tout
s'entend
temps des bruits de pétards en fait
et
au départ je ne réalise pas vraiment
unique et national et que effet les
fidèles vraiment horrifiés de type et
voilà c'est la première des choses
la france est en guerre des actes commis
vendredi soir à paris des près du stade
de france sont des actes de guerre on a
là oui je crois
un discours d'une très grande très
grande force et qu'elle natura
donner de la chair à l'unité nationale
cité nationale qui se discute pas
aujourd'hui la priorité c'est le concret
c'est noël c'est la sécurisation de tous
les lieux recevant du public
c'est organisé des portiques de sécurité
dans tous ses établissements
c'est mettre en cohérence le
fonctionnement de toutes nos forces de
sécurité le plan sentinelles a été
déployé sur paris permettant
l'intervention de l'armée française
tous les services de police de la région
ont rappelé leurs effectifs pour
sécuriser au maximum les lieux très
visitée et renforcer les équipes des
brigades parisienne ce sont des
habitudes qu'il va falloir prendre
depuis le décret d'état d'urgence samedi
dernier les salles de spectacle ont dû
renforcer les contrôles à versailles au
théâtre montansier on procède à une
fouille des sacs mais aussi ouverture
des vestes
un dispositif plutôt bien reçue par les
spectateurs ça n'enlève pas le danger
mais c'est une protection indispensable
contrôle visuel des sacs à main mais
aussi des manteaux les clients se prête
naturellement à ce dispositif de
renforcement de la sécurité
un protocole mis en place à la demande
de la préfecture du département et de la
préfecture de police
en s'intéressant ce que vous me dites
pas ce qu'on nous dit depuis janvier
depuis les attentats de charlie hebdo
une concrètement il ya ce plan
vigipirate renforcé ça veut dire que les
patrouilles sont déjà très sollicités
c'est difficile de leur demander encore
plus alors là vous pointez du doigt un
problème aujourd'hui pas sur les
yvelines il manque 200 fonctionnaires de
police donc on a un manque cruel de
moyens de personnel voilà face à ce
problème mais nous on est un peu
dépourvu on a un problème de matériel il
manque 35 % de nos véhicules
administratifs sont en panne et les
bénévoles qui sont engagés à la croix
rouge sont là dans tous les cas pour
gérer des situations d'urgence donc là
c'était une situation très extrême mais
on avait déjà connu les problèmes du
mois de janvier on avait déjà participé
à tout ce tout c'est toutes ces actions
donc bon je pas dit que les bénévoles
sont rompues parce qu'on n'est jamais
rompu est telle chose moi j'ai mon école
qui est ta place de république donc
carrément on était bon dans notre école
pour participer au don du sang
donc c'était la première fois et là du
coup c'est la deuxième fois sur toute la
france neuf mille dons ont été
enregistrés
un record pour le ffs plus habitué à
recenser deux mille donateurs habituels
les stocks ont permis en ile-de-france
de gérer les besoins actuels pour les
blessés des attentats
alors les jeunes on se parlait dans le
coin génial maman va adorer ça
l'occupera par les parties je voulais
accomplir faire rire malgré les
événements l'équipe du film baby sitting
de a donc décidé de se rendre à l'ugc
lundi soir pour une avant première
devant une salle comble les acteurs ont
assuré le service après vente de cette
comédie qui aura la lourde tâche de
s'imposer début décembre entre james
bond hunger games quand tu vas au cinéma
et que tu passe un bon moment
ça te donne envie de retourner au cinéma
chaque semaine nous donnons la parole
aux enfants également les plus jeunes
livrent leur regard sur l'actualité une
séquence réalisée au collège les saules
à guyancourt tourné cette semaine par
sephora namani et jérémy quesada
et eu des attentats au bataclan au stade
et dans un café ça commençait à 21h16 je
crois c'était 16 minutes après le coup
d'envoi du match est lancé le coup il ya
eu des kamikazes qui ont tiré leurs
gilets explosifs et ça crée un mouvement
de panique en fait à ya eu aussi comment
dire des fusillades dans un café ou un
restaurant je crois 130 morts un peu
près pourquoi ils ont fait ça je
comprends pas à jeter choquer tout
simplement je dis ça fait mal pour les
gens m'aiment même plan même si ces gens
sont ville ils sont choqués donc ça fait
mal pour eux et surtout pour les
familles qui des proches qui sont morts
surtout pauvres
il faut les soutenir j'aime que c'est
qu'ils avaient des familles qui ont
perdu des proches donc l'inde ont donc
aussi un jour de tristesse pour la seule
personne le président s'en est rendu
compte
il a été en hausse jeu en haut du stade
de france et il ya eu une réunion
imprévue en fait ils ont
décidé de fermer les frontières
aériennes terrestres et marines au
moindre bruit fait quelqu'un de débile
si des personnes qui se battent pour
leur religion par un soi-disant leur
union comme la france marche pas comme
ça ils veulent tuer des gens pour leur
faire honneur faire peur et pour qu'on
change la loi et qu'on fasse que me
c'est des gens qui veulent comment dire
qu'ils veulent que toute la terre soit
de la même religion
pour eux il faut qu'on ait faut qu'il
nous fasse peur mais non nous font pas
peur pour continuer à vivre normalement
et il voit là et houdain et toute façon
un jour ou l'autre on arrivera à les
battre parce que si on arrête de vivre
le heureusement ils ont gagné et c'est
pas le but et j'ai quand même peur oui
je vous montre pas pour autant mais
mozart fois j'ai vidé des personnes
pleurer devant les hôpital dont il y
avait plein monde qu'ils demandaient à
ce qu'ils vont être opérés et ce qu'ils
sont sains et saufs à ce que vont mourir
mais je réfléchis je me dis alors est-ce
que ça va s'arrêter est ce que ça va pas
s'arrêter et même très soumises un fard
ni de l'attentât de charles hey jude
parce qu'on est tous en danger
des vendanges est donc tout peut arriver
sans qu'on sache
du coup mais quelques jours françois
nous à bombardier de la syrie il me
semble je pense que là la guerre est
vraiment déclaré n'est pas hors de
géorgie complètement un mot des
programmes de radio sensations à présent
nicolas kirillovitch reçoit pour son
hebdo politique dimanche à 18 heures les
candidats aux élections régionales
premier des deux débats organisés par la
station écoutée tout de suite un extrait
mais moi je vous dirais que le grand
paris devient petit paris si jamais aux
deux modes pas quand même au souverain
c'est à dire au peuple ce qu'il en pense
ici musique n'est d'accord avec cette
idée de référendum citoyen
peu importe le nom un tank lutter nous
votation aussi tout ce que vous voudrez
mais il est évident il arrive un moment
où il faut demander quand même aux gens
ce qu'ils en pensent concernant le grand
paris moi j'observe qu'on vit une
révolution des transports une vraie
révolution de fonds quand vous voyez des
voitures électriques de plus en plus
fréquentes dans les 10 années ça va se
généraliser des voitures sans chauffeur
on a déjà fait un pari je crois à
bordeaux son chauffeur c'est
expérimental dans les 10 années ça va
arriver
le covoiturage blabla car la place de la
voiture va revenir en force
quand j'étais jeune la voiture c'était
la liberté aujourd'hui c'est le mal mais
dans les années qui viennent la voiture
va redevenir un outil de liberté et de
flexibilité
la suite à écouter sur radio sensations
dimanche soir retrouver sur le compte
youtube de la station quant à nous le
journal revient lundi avec florane
parfait il sera question au cours de la
semaine prochaine de la coop 21 et des
opérations menées le sommet mondial de
l'environnement s'ouvre à paris le 29
novembre un sommet remanié pour des
raisons de sécurité pas de sorties
scolaires
pas de marche pour la planète néanmoins
certaines actions sont maintenus comme
l'exposition de sensibilisation à
l'hôtel de ville de montigny le
bretonneux dès 15h30 ce samedi la
plantation symbolique d'un arbre
fruitier juste avant est en revanche
annuler
nous parlerons aussi à de cette
opération menée à versailles pendant la
dernière semaine du mois de novembre
toutes les boulangeries pâtisseries de
la ville participe aux dons pâtissier la
valeur de chaque est clair que vous
allez acheter sera reversé au secours
populaire et l'argent collecté servira à
financer une sortie de noël au cirque
pour les enfants issus de familles
défavorisées du département rendez vous
lundi 18h en direct donc pour un nouveau
journal tout de suite sur tv fils
7-8 week end avec michael et demi
d'euros pour vos loisirs